good morning John this video comes to
you in four parts part number one a very
short story I was in the airport going
home from VidCon and and a woman strolls
up behind me and she is a little bit
peculiar looking and I don't think that
I'm making a judgement to say so I think
she probably means to be she's very
small somewhat voluptuous lots of makeup
and very fancy clothes and with her are
four very big guys to kind of entourage
if you will well I see people all around
kind of fumbling with their cell phone
cameras getting ready being like I think
maybe that is an important person she
has a very distinctive look and I
actually see her later on any YouTube
thumbnail and I figure out who she is
she is Snooki from the Jersey Shore and
if you don't know who Snooki is as far
as I'm concerned you win and somebody
walked up to stallion like stinky can
you take a picture with me and stinky
was like yeah I'll take a picture with
you and they took a picture together but
then somebody walked up to me and was
like hey are you Hank green could I take
a picture with you and Snooki was
confused and that is what it's like when
worlds collide part number two it is
roughly the three year anniversary of
Accio Deathly Hallows getting featured
on the front page of YouTube and if you
don't know what that means that was our
first time when lots of people watched
our videos and John as you mentioned in
a recent Skype conversation this marks
three years of having one of the coolest
weirdest most awesome lives ever and
congratulations you're so cool I bet
there was recently a character in a
major motion picture did the nerdfighter
salute and I bet one of your idols
recently told you that he respects your
work and I bet your brother just won
some kind of fancy literary prize in
Germany so you want some kind of prize
right well here's the pony take your
pony nerd um this isn't a pony it's a
squirrel and why are you wearing a
mustache because I'm the voice inside
your head that tells you the truth that
you are not your achievements and all
your accomplishments are either based on
luck or they're based on cheating right
I got that but why are you wearing a
mustache oh because I was at the store
and there was like a moustache dispenser
and it only cost 50 cents oh cool can I
try it yeah sure I mean no no it's
already for evil version of you oh okay
anyhow part three every year on the
anniversary of Deathly Hallows I write
another song about Harry Potter which I
have done unfortunately there's too much
stuff to talk about
for me to play that whole song for you
today but I will play for you the chorus
looks been so many years no matter how I
try to meet more young adult fiction I
keep coming up dry like water everywhere
and not a drop to drink my frustration
and my agony I've pushed me to the brink
I keep tilting back the glass but I
never taste the water it seems no matter
what I read I think this is not Harry
Potter and finally part number four
Jon's punishment this was actually first
suggested to me at VidCon and I just I
can't let it go because it is so amazing
John we know that you've been doing a
good job on your fitness plan but I
think what nerdfighteria really needs is
a nerd focused workout video I want your
punished to be making a 10-minute long
workout video in which you work the
whole nerd body and your outfit for this
must include a cut-off sweatshirt sort
of cut off at the ribs here a headband
and preferably leg warmers and possibly
a whole body leotard and with that not
only will you be getting in shape but
you will help get all of nerdfighteria
and their top physical condition I
thought that the phrase in shape was a
little bit weird like I'm in awe shape
I'm in the shape of the skinny guy who
still has a very large percentage of
body fat because he has no muscle and
John I hope you're having a very good
time in Germany if you want to go see
John and the sons of admirals there is a
link to information about that down in
the doobly-doo in my pants John I will
see you on Wednesday
in fact you are a phony and everything
that you've ever done was based upon
luck and cheating and half of my
moustache just fell off